my girl Hannah B Hannah Hannah Hannah
she definitely took us for a ride on
last night's men tell all
Luke piece Luke made his dramatic ghost
I turned my goodness at the moment that
had everyone talking had nothing to do
I'm gonna stand here all day until you
know you're not this isn't over for me
yet oh my god whoa all right yeah it was
this drop the podium moment that had
bachelor nation losing it during MOOCs
uninvited rose ceremony returned she
picked up the podium and there was just
silence it's just in the control room
can she do that wait what just happened
and the Hannah beast couldn't beat and
when she finally came face-to-face with
Luke for the first time after kicking
him off the show for a second time I'm
so over being slut-shamed and being felt
like that makes me you never said don't
judge me about the fancy space because I
won't be using that for sex I did not
say that America we had to deal with
Luke pee for way too long
but he is done and I am sorry she cut
that guy off at the knees I was so proud
of her tonight something you didn't see
on TV Luke's 25-minute convo with Chris
was actually two hours long during the
taping and Chris also revealed this
about Luke left to our own devices we
probably would have gotten rid of him in
that storyline earlier to get Hanna on
track for what we would hope to be a
happy ending the big question now will
Hanna get her happily ever after now
that Luke is gone there are just three
men left but Hannah's not sounding very
hopeful you said that Luke broke your
heart this season does anyone else break
your heart
oh well my heart gets broken a lot for a
lot of different reasons on this season
I am here with the beautiful Lake Belen
kaley cuoco but Hayley I got to ask you
off the top what did you think of the
Hanabi Luke P craziness I mean I love
the episode obviously Luke has been
totally horrendous the whole season but
a little felt a little bad for him last
night layouts a little a little like a
duck now calm down universe don't post
it tomorrow that I support Luke thank
you thank you but you know it could we
get it Gocha fighting just like the
tiniest a morsel of a piece at alman do
you love Hanna though yes I think it
Hanna's adorable and I like can we like
Hanna I'm excited to see who she chooses
[Music]